Andrés Saludos fue una manifestación que
comenzó con mucho entusiasmo pudiera
decirse que hasta alegría con cantos
música y que posteriormente pasadas
apenas cuatro horas de su inicio
degeneró y ocurrieron acciones violentas
a lo largo de ese recorrido nosotros
estamos aquí en la plaza de Italia donde
finaliza esa manifestación y hemos hecho
el recorrido completo de inicio a fin y
les voy a relatar lo que hemos visto
inicialmente cerca del bulevar deás un
grupo de extremistas lanzó prendió fuego
al toldo de restaurante La rotonda donde
el presidente Emmanuel macron celebró su
Victoria en el primer turno de la
elección presidencial de 2017 esos
requirió la intervención de los cuerpos
republicanos de seguridad de bomberos
pero también vimos agencias bancadas
bancarias vandalizadas depósitos y
contenedores de basura incendiados
enfrentamientos entre esos elementos
esos individuos extremistas y la policía
cuando llegamos aquí también a la plaza
de Italia
oficiales del orden pues lanzaron gases
lacrimógenos tuvimos Nosotros también el
equipo de France veinticuatro que
abandonar nuestra posición lo que da la
medida de la atención que se ha vivido
en las calles de París y también en
otras ciudades de Francia durante la
jornada de hoy decepcionante por
supuesto esas manifestaciones de poco
civismo como también decepcionante es la
participación que se ha registrado hoy
Apenas poco más de la mitad de la
manifestación del 28 de marzo en muchas
dudas cuestionamientos sobre el poder de
convocatoria de los sindicatos cuando
Todavía faltan ocho días para que el
consejo constitucional dé a conocer su
veredicto sobre precisamente la
constitucionalidad de la Reforma de
pensiones Luis Miguel también hay
denuncias por El excesivo uso de la
fuerza por parte de las autoridades en
estas movilizaciones cuéntenos que se
sabe al respecto
en este momento en todo el país hay
11.500 efectivos policiales desplegados
según el Ministerio del interior y esas
denuncias sobre uso excesivo de la
fuerza llevaron ayer al ministro del
interior
a comparecer ante la asamblea nacional
debido a numerosas pruebas que
demuestran acciones agresivas de las
fuerzas del orden hacia los
manifestantes insultos amenazas de
deportación en el caso de personas que
Aparentemente no eran de nacionalidad
francesa cuando realmente sí y lo eran y
estas cerca de 90 denuncias recibidas
por la defensora de derechos francesa
concierten específicamente a la brigada
de represión de acciones violentas
motorizadas que ha estado en el centro
de la polémica precisamente porque las
los videos y las pruebas demuestran sus
acciones irresponsables hacia
manifestantes que no representaban
amenazas hacia ellos eso llevó a que por
primera vez en la historia la defensora
de derechos
supervisara este jueves las acciones de
mantenimiento del orden en la prefectura
de policía de París